a hundred years from now if somebody
should bring up my name if if it would
still be around it would be nice if
people say geez I I thought he was a
good writer his stories gave me a lot of
pleasure that's what people tell me now
and it's the best thing any writer can
ever hear when I see the characters that
I hope to create on the screen I don't
really think of them as my characters I
I really sit in the theater and I watch
them the way every member of the
audience watches them and at the end of
the movie I usually said that was good
I'm so glad but I worked with artists
who brought them into life who let
people see what they look like and
showed the action there are directors
who added so much to the characters in
their direction and the actors who
brought so much it isn't a one-man field
it is so many people contribute I'm just
happy that I've had a hand in all of
this and I'm happy that even after all
these years someone bothers to interview
me about it I'm really very flattered
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]